this one is from exit outlet that J
reyez posted for us on his behalf
marketing these days is evolving as
audiences of becoming harder to see and
meet face-to-face with online presence
growing what are the best ways to reach
out to your demographics in the
beginning before you can simply by the
audience of the big personally I think
young again some of the things being
disruptive the example gave you almost
20 years ago you want to be how I
actually be part of the conversation how
do I get found first and I think to
Evans point you don't want to do the
same old boring content but there's
loads of obviously digital channels are
where you can connect with your audience
and I think number one so point number
one go where your audiences find out
where your audience is and go there and
you know could be Instagram could be
Facebook could be Twitter and then what
is the exceptional authentic content
that you can server that speaks to the
excitement of your product or service
and then then I think you know our view
of life is then it's all about
recruiting the volunteer army it's all
about excited people when they get hold
of your product they tell all their
friends you know Here I just I just saw
a drone that takes video footage also
awesome I called Lily check it out
online check the YouTube and if you're a
skier or you you dance classes you can
have a little drunk flying around above
you watching all your moves is just all
sorts got a 20 minute battery but there
that is if the products half as good as
YouTube video then it's just going to
blow away and it's going to go viral and
it's going to create a community and the
best what you do it is it's almost like
recruit one volunteer fanatic who is
using your product and that person will
give you a hundred and those hundred
rupee do 10,000 there's 10,000 media
unbirth else because products that are
also services they're also it's all
about being referred by the viral
economy I love it I just fly the drone
that alpha-sensor built-in you know this
other one will check it out earlier and
about on YouTube
have a crisis gesture but if you were
mad ski out or you're one of those
concepts or something crazy like that
then you would have just a ball and it
kind of matches down it's almost like a
bird of prey comes back down when you
want to call it that awesome right so
here's an opportunity to be visionary
because the guys who are going to do it
are the skiers are the surfers are the
whoever like be the entrepreneur who's
walking down the street changing
questions right like whatever your
business is be the first to take this
and applies to your issues that every
skiers going to start doing it but
nobody's doing it in software so how can
you be the software going to do it or
how can you be a baseball player to do
it right these are opportunities to
leverage what's being used in other
industries and apply it to your business
which may be a little more open on that
as well I'm wondering this change right
you remember the old madman message all
around a madman metaphor around kind of
advertising snips I think she'll do seem
feel dude and that was sort of the
advertisers process the walls change
again so it's about do-si-do thick and
there's interview says to do feel think
engage the conversation and it's not a
one gig with this stuff it's all about
the competition and then people will buy
when they're ready to buy but what it
means is if you just start enough as an
entrepreneur the first thing you've got
to do is do and then feel think and also
that the into the measurement around
atletic saan on digital is so powerful
if you've got it wrong you can do real
quick course correction and you can kind
of do the next campaign you treat the
next day with a whole different
sentiment to make sure you kind of get
it right to find out what you want you
know where the audience is and now it's
how do you get new audience sentiment
and the audience frustration and express
that in the way you're going to sell
your products and solution to well and
so I do think the world's changed again
it's no more kind of man my metaphor
it's all about do feel think engage the
conversation you've got to be harder to
conversation my view on it is I think as
an entrepreneur you can't do everything
I think too many entrepreneurs try to do
everything you you have accounts on all
the social media platforms you trying to
post as you were
and as a result everything is mediocre
because you also have a business to run
and show you're just posting boring
stopped and because people say oh you
need to be on Instagram so then you get
on Instagram too and then you're posting
more boring stuff and nothing is working
out for you I would say when the Stevens
Point figure out where your audience is
I would couple that with what are you
great up being able to do like are you
good on camera and can you make video
are you great at taking pictures and
kinks on the Instagram right are you
great with words and can you write blog
posts or LinkedIn post a little sweater
to a couple where the audience is with
something that you're naturally good at
and then can destroy and dominate then
you don't need to spend money right my
youtube channel has 200,000 plus
subscribers and 20 million plus views
and I've spent zero on advertising
because I pour my love into the work and
because it's good people want to share
it and that should be the goal of your
marketing whatever you post I don't just
spam stuff out there if you're going to
make an Instagram post be proud of it
create something that you want to show
your grandkids and say look with
grandpa's Evan made right grandpa will
ever made right like you were proud of
what you made and then people will see
it and share it and then they become
your army like Stephen said out they're
gonna go personal choice so yeah I think
what you've done is awesome and it's a
huge respect sir yeah and you're you're
a legend in the world of occurs and
gaming as well you know I know I know
you love it a nail oh it's you a letter
doubt it but one thing I'm massively
respect also that you've done is the
focus you apply to your message which is
really compelling and easily kind of
that the word believe the focus and
relentless focus and consistency how do
you value for the entrepreneurs out
there kind of watching today the
relevance of the focus and simplicity I
think one it's super helpful for
yourself just it like believe is my
guiding principle I believe everybody
has one word that that guides them for
just have to figure it out and I think
too many people live by accident and are
living by reacting to things in the
external environment set of purposely
setting forth to create a plan for
themselves and as entrepreneurs this is
something we can do right
we're breaking free of the box of
typical world and we're creating out the
cream of everyone for ourselves and
people around us and so it's understand
what you saying for helps me one with
like making decisions like Jesus about
believe or not if it's not I'm not going
to do it right ah you know I love
working with you guys I love having
these settings there's a lot of
companies that I don't work with because
you're not about to leave because they
don't care about entrepreneurs really
just want to sell product and so having
that one word helps make a difference
for me to say yes or no gym and also
housekeeping motivate I have a big goal
I want to have a billion entrepreneur's
you know part of what I do the things
that I create I want it to be at scale
you know I love helping one-on-one
entrepreneurs it feeds my soul but I
want to be able to have a huge impact
and so making videos on YouTube right in
my book doing speaking engagements
you're the things that have the
potential of reach massive audience and
have massive impact right more than just
Denton universe right this is what I
want to create and so I think having
that clarity and focus helps as
entrepreneurs because you're doing too
many things you're everything from the
CEO to the janitors you're responsible
for the marketing as well as product
creation as well as customer service as
well as cleaning up you know the shop
and you know being able to focus on
these things only helps so in terms of
marketing again I will come back to you
pick what you're really good at
naturally talented that combined with
where your audiences and just focus on
that and don't get distracted by people
telling you these should be on linkedin
or you need to be on Instagram if that's
not where your audiences and what you're
not really good I um I mean I believe in
believe it's it's everywhere it's well
the dosage of what I just looked again
the level of spam in aneema to create
this 20 billion a day say so it's just
no good to do whatever else is to it
because no one reads this stuff you got
a good where the audience is to Evans
point find and really seeing to unlock
their dreams in terms of the products
and services and be part of that
conversation and then the consistency of
focus is so compelling and and you
gained huge trust and I think
says it always about authenticity it's a
really undervalued word but authenticity
of everything and and that's how you
create this volunteer army of Raven
fanatics who are your best salespeople
that your fans and they believe in what
you're trying to do an HR change the
world and they get excited about a
fright and you know and I know when you
get excited about something you see some
really cool technology you tell me
friends about it and literally you've
told hundreds of people thousands of
follows within seconds I'm so excited
right now I'm getting hot I want I
almost might take off my hoodie it's too
hot the energy is awesome in here a